welcome to this video playing then helgi
from Iceland and I am and I am let's see
only check they all play this stuff now
yo check so we have a Moscow variation
of them the solian there should be five
check very solid safe line leading to my
Roxy bind type of positions yeah that's
a very very solid set up I wonder there
was this game of even Shooks but it's
it's different right yeah this was
without knight c6 mmmm okay yeah i think
if i'm not mistaken this even the
possibility to play quick e6 and t5 but
not i'm not entirely sure it's been a
while since I'm studied this line
thank you fine ok I'm trying to prepare
d5 if I do that now is it it's also very
boring very boring and maybe at the end
not even equal so let's let's try to
play the bit more complicated maybe not
a good idea yeah I was thinking maybe be
five but it can easily be a weakness the
spawn now Randy's got 95 of course it's
just down a bad idea hmm ok player
waiting move age 5 s sometimes the
necessary a useful move Bishop h6 type
of ideas one move eh porn to irritate
white hmm now now I might get a grip
here with a 5 yeah but this also can be
can be weak I had push-up age six ideas
maybe yeah maybe now
therefore I take you for so we have the
straight now and if I go Quincy five now
takes rook takes and I'm threatening a
five yeah maybe trading some pieces
serve is probably a good idea this
position is suffering a bit from lack of
space yes this is a this was possible
hmm what do I take a five now is this is
that big we could draw back to that I
don't see and don't see a big drawback
even I even have the D file now or wait
he's got a big back rank I'm thinking
about rook here and Queen d2 this is
really irritating yeah this is a
somewhat shaky now from white somewhat
shaky now p is also looked it to look T
to queenie queenie to maybe I also have
stuff like 35 okay but let's do that
first really should be okay the night
does not have a good square 93 I just
take because of the back rank maybe he
needs to retreat to g1 but I have Queen
a two on that yeah but now i have i have
various tricky moves quincy three for
example 23
yeah why not 23 what does he do now I'm
attacking this rock and ok and just have
if I cannot take him
and didn't really just didn't really
bring any big benefits simply because I
cannot take him
he might play Queen to g5 intending
night age five
I just thot 97 and 25 is this Oh 40
seconds ahead I completely ignored the
clock check now a must-read now and then
that's this a really good end game
because I win and win the queenside 30
seconds is not much though
Wow very irritating move he's got that
93 93 I tricked me what the heck my
break and now I didn't have a moose I
don't have a moose this was two black
resins a white was was already busted in
this position and I just I just gave it
away like that yeah yeah now he's okay
again so I need to I need to find the
better move that would be true maybe
maybe something really prophylactic like
a queen here if you don't believe me and
that he's busted become compass on minus
two which is no surprise because this is
totally dominating those two pieces and
carry the threat years night age 785
almost winning the Queen and there are
all kinds of war's end game saddest
losing this is really really stupid
after he really played this badly and
giving them allowing this a 546 exchange
and here yeah this is this isn't Chuck
this is already a problem and of course
I had a hell had a complete
hallucination here I must take of course
I thought he can take here but i have a
check Queen g7 I said just overlooked
Queen g7 this is why I went here this is
still um this is still ok for me don't I
don't lose here right away as men and it
was not intended of course but this is
term sell a playable position because of
the active rook
yeah Wow losing this is really idiotic
now there's even the question if they
were better moves I mean yeah but this
is strong i mean- to what more do you
want okay thanks for watching